لفهم التوترات
بين الناتو وروسيا حول أوكرانيا
بشكل أفضل ، من الجدير إلقاء نظرة على التاريخ
وإلقاء نظرة فاحصة على خريطة
في الحرب الباردة أوروبا انقسمت إلى
حد ما في دولتين من دول الناتو في
معاهدة وارسو الغربية وهيمنة موسكو
في  شرقًا ولكن
بلدًا ما بعد الحرب الباردة أرادت دولة بعد أخرى الانضمام إلى
الناتو وانتقلت
إلى حدود روسيا لفهم سبب شعور روسيا
بالقلق من أن الخريطة الطبوغرافية
مفيدة ،
فهناك سلسلة جبال تمتد عبر
أوروبا جبال الكاربات الآن من
بحر البلطيق هنا
إلى  حيث يبدأ الكاربات هناك ،
فهذه الأرض مسطحة ومن خلال تلك
الأرض المسطحة جاء نابليون
وهتلر الفرنسي والألمان والعديد من
الآخرين الذين غزوا روسيا من هذا
الاتجاه وهذا يجعل روسيا
متوترة للغاية لذلك تسعى إما إلى
سد تلك الفجوة عن طريق  احتلالها أو إن لم يكن
حيث تنفتح الأرض على أرض مستوية
تريد
السيطرة عليها على الأقل في عام 2014 كان رد فعلها
هو احتلالها و  ن ملحق شبه جزيرة القرم في
أوكرانيا وميناء سيباستوبول المائي الدافئ
الذي يمنح الأسطول الروسي إمكانية الوصول
من البحر الأسود إلى البحر الأبيض المتوسط
هناك إل
الممرات المحيطية الكبرى في العالم ، ك
ا أنه يخمر الحرب الأهلية في من
قة دونباس من أجل  إنشاء
منطقة عازلة صغيرة
الآن يبدو أن بوتين أكثر طموحًا الآن
إذا كان هناك غزو ،
فمن المحتمل أن يمر أحد السيناريوهات الأربعة
باحتلال كامل وضم منطقة دونباس
إلى أعلى من ذلك الانتقال
من شبه جزيرة القرم والانضمام إلى كل هذه
الأراضي  حتى تصبح المنطقة العازلة
أكبر مستوى من ذلك
السباق على طول ساحل البحر الأسود
وصولاً إلى أوديسا وهي
مدينة ناطقة بالروسية
تضم كامل الساحل
وتعزل أوكرانيا عن البحر الأسود والأكثر
طموحًا من بينكم  افعل كل السيناريوهات
السابقة وستنقل القوات إلى bailaroos الصديقة لروسيا وتنزل
من بيلاروسيا
عبر ما يسمى
بالأهوار priepet التي تم تجميدها في الشتاء
وأنت تطوق عاصمة أوكرانيا التي
تسمى كييف ، فإن أفضل وقت للقيام بذلك هو
الشتاء لأنه سيكون
تقدمًا ميكانيكيًا
وتحتاج الأقسام الآلية إلى
أرض متجمدة صلبة
وهذه استراتيجية ولكن من المهم
فهم المكان الذي توجد فيه أوكرانيا في
قلوب روسيا أو في
بدأت ثقافتها الروسية في علم النفس في كييف ، وهي
المكان الذي تأسست فيه روسيا في نهاية المطاف ،
أعني أنها انتقلت شرقًا
عبر موسكو ، لكنهم ما زالوا يعرفون في
خيالهم الجماعي أن جذور
ثقافتهم تكمن في قلب أوكرانيا.
يتحدثون الروسية ،
هناك علاقة سلافية
وهناك أيضًا حقيقة أن
العديد من الناس أرثوذكس روسي في
معتقداتهم الدينية ،
وهذا من القلب
ويلعب بالفعل دورًا في التفكير الروسي
[موسيقى]